freunde jetzt willkommen zu diesem video
ich habe jetzt schon riesige angst denn
ich es heute ist das training ich hoffe
ich spreche das richtig aus das ist eine
schwäbische delikatesse und wird auch
als das am klicks riechende essen der
gesamten welt bezeichnet falls ihr euch
fragt warum ich das mache wenn ich hier
auf meinen wunderschönen poly guckt ich
habe das assassin's creed logo auf
meinem politik dieses videos habe ich
eine zusammenarbeit mit assassin's creed
walhalla mit dem neuen teil der jetzt
raus kommt und walhalla der name sagt
schon das wird sich um die wikinger zeit
und die haben bekanntlicherweise unter
anderem solche sachen gegessen
deshalb dachte ich mir ich stelle mich
der challenge ich will probieren den
streaming lecker zu machen ich werde
ihnen traditionell zu bereiten und ich
werde ihn pur essen ich glaube bei
letzterem wird es nicht gut ausgehen es
gibt wirklich viele leute die sich davon
schon übergeben mussten oder leute die
ihre wohnung verlassen mussten was auch
der grund dafür ist dass wir das hier
draußen machen weil sie diese dose in
der wohnung geöffnet haben die
verschiedenen dosen sind einmal oscars
training das ist ganz so streaming damit
ihr wisst was das ist das sind
heringsfilets die irgendwie hier drin
verkehren deshalb verbeugt sich auch die
dose hier so schön weil er richtig druck
drauf ist ich werde beides öffnen gucken
was schlimmer richtig habe auf jeden
fall krank ist noch nicht dass noch
nichts das sind die beiden dosen die wir
glaube ich noch sehr viel nasen
schmerzen bereiten werden ich fange mit
dem denken schlimmsten an mit der dose
wo die ganzen heringe drin sind wir
müssen wissen die sind wirklich ganz
also mit innereien und sowohl für
nachvollziehbar das wikinger das gerne
gegessen haben keine video gesehen da
hat das über es gespritzt erst
aufgemacht haben kate und jacobson mit
mir wie gegen gerade richtig auf distanz
haben etwas vorbereitet
handschuhe anziehen was übrigens gerade
gesagt habe dass jemand aus seiner
wohnung geflogen das war das streaming
gegessen hat ist kein spaß sondern das
ist hier in köln passiert hat eine dose
geöffnet wurde deshalb fristlos
gekündigt es wird also seine
berechtigung haben wird das möglichst
weit weg vom körper halten mein herz
schlägt sich die schnell und los geht
darin um mein gott das ist kein spaß der
geruch und die source kommt raus die
jungen bei ihren spaß ich meinen text
oh mein gott oh gott ich muss schnell
durchziehen mein gott ich mache sich
auch gerufen
das riecht nach fort ich dachte es
riecht nach fisch probieren mozart
kannst du einmal kokott gehört das soll
ich esse nicht war aber wichtig zuhause
bedeutet jeder force michael spa damit
aussieht so schlimm aus weil ich daran
richten dave traut sich haben parallel
auch mal die filets darstellen
das riecht alles absolut widerlich hier
gerade aber das lecker zu machen vom
geruch wird eine unmögliche challenge
ich glaube ich doch schlimmer ich bin
halt auch so schon kein großer fan von
so normalen hering der jetzt nicht
ungefähr fünf monate vergammelt ist okay
das war der erste bürger der favorit
taxis leute das sind die filets ein
fisch für dich ist fast so leute wir
legen jetzt parallel während wir alles
andere vorbereiten
die filets oder ein zwei filets in
butter milch ein
aber ich hoffe dass das die geschmack
vielleicht ein bisschen neutralisiert so
ein beherzter griff bekommen eigentlich
zu kambodscha aber es geht nicht mehr
unter das marinierte jetzt werden wir
alles andere vorbereitet ich mache mal
die pannierstraße für so pannierstraße
nehmen wir einfach zwei eier sondern
drüben etwas mehr
dieser geruch ist die ganze zeit präsent
und ich bereite jetzt parallel die
traditionelle weise vor jahren das essen
kann
die zwiebel würfeln wir und dazu werfen
wir noch eine tomate so ist man das
ganze nämlich eigentlich benutzt man zur
streaming nämlich viel mehr als gewürz
in schweden ist nämlich nicht der die
kattas wir haben jetzt alle zutaten die
man für einen traditionellen zur
streaming web benötigt werde ein klein
bisschen von den filets nehmen und das
nutzen um das zu würzen wir nehmen
richtig dick schmandt weil das ist meine
einzige hoffnung in diesem rap also no
job
ich mag zwiebel nicht mal so gerne dass
er jetzt folgt das leben
der geruch kommt immer mal wieder rüber
es ist wirklich unglaublich und das
schreit wir zu klein und nehme davon
kleine bisher in den rapid ich will das
nicht essen die leute es ekelt mich an
ich glaube mehr nimmt man gar nicht und
das nehmen wir jetzt hier und streuen
das rein ich finde es wirklich crazy
dass man das ist später in diesem video
leute zeige ich euch auch noch ein
rennen en trachten bot rennen das im
rahmen der assassin's creed 2 change
hatte mit dem mountain war auch
geisteskrank richtig coole aufgabe aber
erstmal probiere ich jetzt das erste tor
warten drüber und zwiebel ich mache den
anfang nehmen wir so ein schönes warum
hasst das durch drei geteilt weil ihr
auch probieren wollen einfach ein tempel
kamera hier besonders einfach da wo man
hätte nicht daran riechen sollen augen
zu ihm durchkam
man sollte temperatur somit dem wirbel
um an gott der geschmack ist so intensiv
vor leute es ist so wild august darüber
hätten wir auch nachdenken können leute
der fisch lockt einfach die hunde an
aber ich habe den ersten bissen genommen
ich muss euch so viel sagen es ist
essbar
man ist das und denkt sich so 'oh mein
gott wie viel geschmack wie intensiv
kann das sein
aber ich glaube dass ich habe den
wikinger ps schauen wir bestanden ich
hab traditionellen streaming gegessen
ich verstehe warum das pur die hölle ist
wer von euch traut sich jakob will
lieber die von mir lecker gemachte
variante versuche mir dann nehme ich
hier so ein gott was bist du des
wahnsinns er hat einfach das komplett er
hat habt ihr dem wissen gesehen gibt es
kommst du bist auch du bist auch ein
wikinger das sind aber nicht ausnehmen
finger gerade lässt einen so wirklich
schüttelt frage ist nur wann das endlich
aus meinem mund wieder verschwindet
dieser geschmack ja der post müssen wir
bei dave aus dem rathaus qualys es ist
das schlimmste ist durch das schlimmste
bevor ich jetzt probiere das ganze
lecker zuzubereiten zeige ich euch das
drachenbootrennen vom mégane ist und
euch viel spaß ich muss auch der geruch
ein bisschen ertragen ich weiß das
klingt verrückt wir sind wirklich ein
drachenboot rennen gefahren dass das
hier gerade sieht sind keine spiel
aufnahmen sondern aufnahmen von
ferngesteuerten mini boten die auf einer
originalgetreuen karte gefahren sind wir
mussten so eine acht fahren auf dieser
karte stellt euch das hier mal ein
und ich war ziemlich last in der ersten
runde muss ich sagen ich bin vielleicht
auch das ein oder andere mal gecrasht
aber nur die erste runde zum einspielen
in die zweite runde geht jetzt los
die ersten
ein bisschen chaotisch als uns
ausprobiert haben aber jetzt habe ich
das spiel raus dann kam auch schon die
zweite runde was soll ich sagen ich bin
die ganze zeit und wenn die gefahren
habe verkackt okay leute jetzt kommt die
finale runde gibt es nur damit ihr
versteht um was es geht wenn ich dieses
spiel gewinnen dann fahre ich gegen haft
tor bemannten das finale rennen und es
sieht gut aus es sieht immer noch gut
aus es sieht immer noch gut aus
ich habe einfach gewonnen aber ich
glaube jetzt fertigen behaupten wir sind
unseren kräften rolle
simone leute ich glaube das ist wirklich
ein guter zeitpunkt um einfach mal danke
zu sagen an assassin's creed ubisoft die
sitzt sie einfach mit einem krassen
schauspiel und einem der stärksten
männer der welt und fahren
drachenbootrennen
[Musik]
demnach verspricht weiter nein einfach
verfahren ja ok this is amazing grace
war mega es heute weiter mit dem video
du willst lieber nicht weg dafür ist
jetzt bestimmt 20 minuten her dass wir
das zeug in die bütt amerika und haben
jetzt hat sich das öl vor und dann
frittieren wir ich habe hier die
buttermilch getränkten filet es die gebe
ich noch mal in das eigelb schönen durch
mengen es riecht schon weniger schlimm
muss ich sagen durch die buttermilch gut
dass muss jetzt schön pariert werden
weil zitiert schmecken scheinbar besser
alles also es soll so gut frisiert sein
wie es nur irgendwie geht leute weil ich
glaube dass das einzige was irgendwie
erträglich machen könnte es ist an
passieren dass öls auf temperatur ich
gebe jetzt wie viel es hinein nur als
duo 23
der geruch kommt richtig krass baut aber
ich sehe das als positives weil der
gestank jetzt gerade rauskommt dann
verliert er vielleicht also ich muss
ehrlich sagen seitdem rap gerade eben
habe ich leider überhaupt keinen hunger
mehr und verzicht sind deswegen
vielleicht beim zitierten
da muss jakob dann hinhalten so werde
ich mich ja zwischendurch okay wir
fahren jetzt in schwarz mit dem
schnittlauch
ich gucke nicht mal nämlich mal mehr
steinweiss war egal ich schwöre das wird
immer schlimmer
okay wir hol dir jetzt und macht den
schreibtisch raus mein gott meine hand
stinkt durch den gummi handschuh nicht
so intensiv aber die prozent ist bitte
dieser geruch also wenn ihr nicht wisst
was das hier ist könnte man denken es
ist und keiner casey viel lieber wisst
ihr was leute damit das ganze land in
bleibt mache ich das hier noch mit den
dreien ich hoffe dass es dadurch besser
schmeckt weil es halt eben so krank
stinkt dass der geruch wie verflogen ist
muss ich sagen es riecht nicht mehr
besonders schlimm checkt ihr das viele
geld komplett durch ich nehme es in
großen wissen ich hatte kein ekel zu
keinem punkt ich schwöre bei gott ich
mache das nicht um euch vor zusagen des
besten was gut schmeckt oder so es kommt
ultra salzig dieser hering ist nämlich
einfach krank seid ich aber man kann das
so essen ja ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
ich das schaffe profico ich schwöre auf
alles schmeckt halt super salzig aber
dieser kranke eklige oxidieren de
schimmelnde fisch geschmack ist nicht
mehr da hat mich etwas aufzuführen
ich bin richtig sauer auf mich ich habe
einen weg gefunden wie man das lecker
zubereiten kann also wie gesagt das ist
super intensiv ich hatte nicht mit
diesem ausgang gerechnet hatte ja ich
muss mich übergeben aber natürlich habe
ich bin ein würdiger wikinger
deshalb steckt auf jeden fall den link
der beschreibung zu dessen street
ballack ich bleibe jetzt dabei wikinger
im spiel zu sein statt im echten leben
aber ich bin stolz als gut